salut c'est jean jacques goldman fake ou
réalité aujourd'hui nous allons mettre à
l'épreuve notre capacité à sentir le
fake riz alors fake c'est le jeu auquel
vous allez jouer aujourd'hui le jeu te
montrera 15 photos certaines sont des
originaux et d'autres ont été retouchés
édités ou photoshopée comme cet homme
aux abdos divin pour chaque photo
cliquer sur le bouton approprié pour
soumettre ta réponse si la photo est un
fake le jeu te montrera la photo avant
qu'elle ait été photoshopée combien de
bonnes réponses peux tu faire hockey est
ce que toutes ces heures à 7 perdus sur
internet vont nous servir
c'est la question que je me pose à
chaque fois que je vais 4h30 sur ce
puits en première photo c'est parti on
commence bon ça m'a l'air vrai mais ça
fait vraiment cette taille
est-ce qu'en vrai la photo du reptile
n'est pas carrément en plus gros plan et
on a des tours et pour le mettre sur un
doigt au gros plan mais que ça fait pas
cette taille mais c'est totalement
photoshopée quoi mais le truc fait cette
taille vieux donc c'était une sorte de
caméléon on va pas se mentir les camions
sont des petits reptiles de taille
modérée les plus petites espèces font
près de 3 cm de long ah merde mais
j'étais persuadé que c'était que c'était
minimum ça merde c'est pas grave on
panique pas il nous reste la photo des
bâches mormeck s'est pas fait ça perd
photoshopée je vois pas l'intérêt vous
de choper ça en vrai tu vas dans le
champ à côté de chez toi tu prends une
photo yassa et tabac non c'est la vérité
quoi maintenant mais qui rajoute une
vache ou une photo il ya des vaches déjà
pas mal par très mal ça c'est
photoshopée est pourquoi est ce que
cette taxe serait fou d'attendre règle
on va regarder les aigles d'ailleurs je
vois pas en quoi c'est mieux de jouer
juste un mec est debout sur le manche
c'est vrai au [ __ ]
ouais je me mets la pression pour rien
alors je vais voir un truc parfaitement
va je crois que c'est un fake c'est
juste des montagnes qui suggérerait
photoshopée l'eau il aurait pu rajouter
la montagne avery a pas cette grosse
montagne là tu penses non non je suis
sûr que le truc c'est que ce gros bloc
n'est pas là sur la photo originale bon
on va dire vrai au oui c'est bon ça
faire ouvre un lourd ce blanc qui a
chassé le poisson le poisson à l'air en
bon état comme quand tu l'achètes au
casino à côté de chez toi comment cette
tour aurait pu choper le poisson sans
l'abîmer parce qu'on dirait pas mais ce
truc à les griffes comme as mon gars
fake
et bien voilà et pas de poisson à la
base ball bon alors où un avion qui
passe sous le golden gate
on dit que l'avion était pris en photo
sous un certain angle de vue est que le
point a été pris en photo sous un autre
angle de vue donc quand tu mets les deux
ensemble vous ne m'aurez pas après et
forcément un mec qui passe en avion sous
golden gate un jour c'est terrible
c'était un trio puisque le mec fait dans
l'avion qu'ils veulent te faire croire
que c'est du fait qu'ils veulent que tu
y crois pas mais en vrai est ce que ce
n'est pas juste la vérité un an y avait
vraiment pas l'avion je savais que cette
photo était bizarre c'est qu'à moins de
chouettes pourquoi il aurait photoshopée
d'accord le gars il n'avait pas d'idée à
ça il ya moyen que ce soit photoshopée
vous savez les photos d'animaux
les mecs sont payés pour la photo soit
la plus belle possible donc c'est
possible qu'il ait pris ce espèce de
truc jaune là et qu'ils les aient
multiplié pour une belle harmonisation
de la photo donc on va dire fec 3/4 pour
rien je suis mauvais on à 50% ça va ça
va quand le mec il réussit à prendre la
photo bon moment d'une [ __ ] de baleine
avec une mouette c'est un fake c'est un
fake
voilà la moitié était pas là la moye n
était pas là au besoin on est un fils
soit votre de chiens c'est même pas la
même oreille mais c'est totalement
photoshopée quoi m'a dit non mais qu il
est un cran sous chiens mais ça c'est à
des scientifiques qui ont créé en
laboratoire sont possibles le matin on
dirait carrément cette photo là mes
qualités photoshopée la photo du quiz
est ce que le quiz n'est pas en train de
prendre pour un con donc ceci est une
cathédrale où une église
pourquoi est ce que ça aurait été
photoshopée ce qui peut être photoshopée
là dedans je pense c'est du feq
oui voilà on n'a plus eu tu risques au
baccalauréat
ok on a 6 sur 11 le port le port est ce
que le port est un faux port mais non
mais non mes mecs là je suis en train de
perdre ton point c'est vrai ces photos
d'un porte [ __ ] faut arrêter les
conneries
hazard a causé photoshop l'éclat était
pas là la route était pas allé au fake
voilà vim
elle faisait pas de lui ces salles
astuces sont faire des belles photos
nuit c'est finalement de faire des
photos de jour et d'ouvrir photoshop
points ex-aequo quai alors là je pense
qu'un délai avec les nuages que ce soit
y avait des nuages avant les eaux
retirer soit ils ont rajouté un nuage ou
deux si l'on photoshopée c'est que le
ciel était tout bleu ou qui avait trop
de nuages mais ça me paraît quand même
je pense est une vraie [ __ ] le ciel
est souple le ciel était tout bleu je le
dis pourquoi je m'écoute pas ici fait ce
[ __ ] de raccoon
ça c'est vrai nom alors là par contre si
je peux me permettre si c'est pas une
vraie photo je ferme la chaîne youtube
pour le plus grand malheur des tueurs
game over 9 sur 15 60% mais écoutez
faite le et puis on compare voilà ce que
vous avez vu la vidéo maintenant pas aux
frais 100% donc ça compte pas et ouais
je regarde cette vidéo sur fake ou
réalité n'était pas là mais ça vous a
plu et je trouve ça ouf de d'arriver à
devenir complètement parano en fait on a
tellement vu de fake et des trucs barré
sur internet que maintenant on a
beaucoup de mal à croire même aux trucs
les plus vrai [ __ ] peu plus confiance
en personne
2016 c'est terrible j'espère qu'elle
applique de jeu j'arriverai mieux à
différencier les photos faillite ou pas
fake surtout sur tender énorme blaye à
la tenue prochaine d'une auberge de me
regarder forcez-vous bien des tours de
piste
fake ou réalité gros fake